Hello again, SCP Fans!
We’ve once again sparked up the Anom-O-Tron
6000, our state-of-the-art supercomputer that
takes countless data streams from the SCP
Foundation’s various anomalies, and allows
us to simulate potential scenarios that could
never normally occur.
For example, what if Boba Fett, one of fiction’s
most iconic galactic bounty hunters, took
on the Sarkic menace that is The Flesh That
Hates?
Well…
Let’s press the button and find out!
A long time ago in a barely explored corner
of a galaxy far, far away…
The rhythmic blink of bright red emergency
lights brought the hunter back to consciousness.
Beneath the tinted visor of his helmet, his
vision was still blurry from the blow he had
taken to the head as his ship had jolted to
a stop.
Blinking away the haze clouding his eyesight,
he focused on the light still flashing up
at him from the console in front of the seat
he was strapped into.
Wait, was he?
He lifted a gloved hand to double-check; still
secure, buckled in tight.
Finally able to see again, the bounty hunter
turned to the console, checking the readouts
on the circular screens of his ship’s cockpit.
It didn’t take running a quick diagnostic
for him to realize his predicament.
As durable and heavily armored as his trusty
Firespray was, the vessel had taken a pretty
nasty hit.
He knew he was taking a risk flying through
an area of space controlled by the infamous
Crimson Dawn.
The crime syndicate maintained a fragile alliance
with the hunter’s slothful, slug-like employer,
but after spotting his ship trying to pass
through their territory undetected, they had
retaliated.
Sending a squad of ships after the Firespray,
and outmaneuvering them hadn’t been easy,
especially the smaller, single-person fighters
that could zip around at much faster speeds
than the hunter’s heavy gunship.
But the syndicate had used its fighters as
merely a distraction, drawing his attention
away from the larger attack ship drawing in
from the rear.
Receiving a full blast from an ion cannon
was bad enough; the energy bolt had struck
the hunter’s ship, serving a direct hit
that slowed his vessel down to a crawl, albeit
still intact… for now.
Ion blasts weren’t designed to cause lasting
damage to a ship, only to disrupt all the
electronic systems on board.
From his cockpit, the bounty hunter knew exactly
why his adversaries had done this; they wanted
to capture him alive, and possibly take his
Firespray too.
He wasn’t about to let that happen, the
ship had been passed down to him by his father,
along with the armor he now wore, that made
him instantly recognizable as one of the most
feared hunters in the galaxy.
But, having his ship rendered without navigation
systems or control over the engines, meant
he couldn’t steer it clear of the path of
an oncoming fighter.
The smaller ship moved to swerve out of the
way, only too late.
It clipped the Firespray’s wing, causing
the hunter to lurch forward and hit his head
as his ship spun out of control, drifting
away, lost in space.
By the time he came back around, he found
himself adrift in an unfamiliar, uncharted
corner of the galaxy.
His ship was still badly damaged, running
on a reserve of emergency power that was quickly
depleting.
The hunter fumbled with the controls, taking
a look at the star map on his display.
He didn’t recognize this quadrant or even
the system he was in.
There was one planet looming ahead, a green
and blue world with a single neighboring moon…
It was then the hunter realized what that
red light had been warning him about.
In its damaged state, the Firespray had been
caught in the planet’s gravitational pull,
and was now hurtling towards its surface.
Holding on tight, bracing himself for impact,
Boba Fett prepared for a particularly bumpy
landing.
The entire ship buckled as it passed through
the planet’s upper atmosphere, the metalwork
creaking as scraps were torn away from the
outer hull by the extreme g-force.
Boba yanked at the steering columns, barely
able to change the course of his ship’s
descent.
The power was still minimal after the ion
attack, practically running on fumes.
Looking out of the large front viewport, Fett
could see streaks of heat as his Firespray
plummeted to the surface.
He had an idea, a risky move but it might
just work.
If it didn’t, then his storied career as
the galaxy’s most infamous bounty hunter
might just come to an unremarkable, anticlimactic
ending.
Pulling at the controls, he repositioned the
ship’s remaining fin-like wing – the one
still mostly operational – and angled the
Firespray so that its rear boosters were facing
towards the planet, its internal gyro system
keeping him sat upright.
Still tumbling straight down, now in landing
position, all Boba could do was hold tight
and pray… prayers that were answered when
the console lit up with an alert.
The heat of re-entry had jumpstarted the engines,
reigniting the gunship’s propulsion system;
not enough for sustained flight, but adequate
to allow the hunter to control his descent,
and lessen the impact of the rough landing.
The Firespray came to a crashing halt in the
snow, still mostly intact, but too badly damaged
to take off.
Clambering his way out, Boba Fett examined
the wreckage of his ship.
It had been in far worse scrapes over the
years, but every time the Firespray sustained
damage, he couldn’t help but think of what
his father, Jango, would say – or his donor,
as some would call him, given that Boba was
a pure, unaltered genetic clone of his ‘dad’.
Turning around, he looked out over the expanse
of the frozen region he’d crashed on.
The wind carried with it an icy bite; Fett
was only shielded from it by the insulated
flight suit he wore under his green-painted
plates of Beskar steel armor.
He lowered the antenna on his Mandalorian
helmet, using its viewfinder to survey the
horizon.
Instantly, his eyes spotted a sign, a worn
sheet of metal, half-buried in the snow.
There was something off about this sign though,
that instantly told Boba he wasn’t on Hoth,
Illum, Orto Plutonia, or any other ice planet
he knew of.
He trudged closer to the sign, crossing the
frozen tundra alone, the cape over his shoulder
whipping in the freezing cold gale.
Where there was a sign, there could easily
be civilization, maybe even somewhere Fett
could get parts to fix his inherited ship.
He forced himself not to stop and examine
the sign, but couldn’t help glancing at
it as he passed.
Boba couldn’t recognize the lettering written
on it at all, not the characters that had
been printed on the metal, nor the word painted
over it in red.
At first, he’d thought it might be Aurebesh,
but the closer he got he realized it was a
language he didn’t understand.
Continuing on past it, Boba tried to put thoughts
of the sign out of his head, unaware that
it read ‘Lake Baikal, Siberia’… and
that someone had painted the Russian word
for ‘Run’ over it.
It didn’t take long for Boba to reach the
civilization that he was looking for, or what
was left of it anyway.
The small fishing town reminded him a little
of the city of Mos Espa back on Tattooine,
although it looked to have been abandoned
for quite some time.
The rickety buildings were all constructed
out of wooden planks, with a thick coating
of frost over almost every surface.
As Boba marched further in, a gunslinger walking
into a frozen ghost town, there was almost
total silence.
The cold winds had died down to barely a whisper
now.
The stranded bounty hunter looked around,
finding no signs of anything nearby.
No spaceport, no Jawas he could trade with,
no townsfolk to ask for directions, no signs
of life…
Something moved behind him, causing Boba to
instinctively whip around to face it, producing
his EE-3 carbine blaster
with a draw speed rivaled by few of the fastest
hands in the galaxy.
His weapon was trained on nothing, whatever
had caused the sound was nowhere to be seen.
Keeping his gun up and at the ready in one
hand, Boba reached for a button on one of
his gauntlets.
Within his helmet, the pure white of the snow
blinked away, replaced by a blue filter, providing
him with a head’s up display that highlighted
any nearby heat signatures.
There was a trail on the ground just a few
feet from him; not tracks, mind you, just
a single streak of warmth left carved through
the snow.
Cautiously, Boba followed it.
The trail curved around a nearby shack, and
then disappeared through a hole that had been
punched through one of its walls; the wooden
planks it was built from were all splintered
outwards, as if something large had burst
out of it.
Inside the shack had been coated in enough
frost to freeze everything solid; cups and
plates at the dinner table looked like they’d
been encased in carbonite.
Looking around the dark, abandoned interior,
Boba barely noticed something slithering down
towards him from the ceiling…
A winding, fleshy appendage whipped around
Boba’s arm, locking it tightly in place.
He pulled against it with all his strength,
but the bounty hunter couldn’t free his
hand, or the blaster he was holding.
Turning to see his attacker through the boards
of the upper floor, Fett could make out a
writhing, massive shadow attached to the long,
grotesque appendage that now had him in an
armlock.
In all his years of bounty hunting, he’d
never seen a species like it; whatever it
was, his Beskar and flight suit were protecting
it from feeling its disgusting, slimy grip
against his skin.
Although he wasn’t too keen on being held
by this monster for much longer.
With his free hand, Boba tried to wrench the
tentacle off him, only to feel it snaking
further and tighter around his arm, bending
it in the opposite direction his elbow was
meant to bend.
Boba grunted, stifling a scream under his
helmet as he felt his arm on the verge of
snapping.
But the pain brought back reminders of his
lessons, his training under his various mentors
– his father, Aurra, even old Bane.
Even with his blaster arm ensnared, a good
bounty hunter was never unarmed.
Knocking the gauntlet on his free arm against
his leg to activate it, he lifted his first
upwards as a streak of flame erupted from
the Mandalorian vambrace, setting fire to
the wooden floor above… and the creature,
which shrieked in pain as it caught alight,
relinquishing its grip.
Thinking fast, and moving at a speed to match,
Boba leaped out of the way as the huge monster
came crashing through the burning wood planks.
Had he not rolled to a safe distance just
in time, then it would have landed on him,
crushing the bounty hunter under its weight.
Back on his feet, Boba spun on his heel and
opened fire with his now-freed blaster, each
blast of the red laser light illuminating
the horrific sight of what had attacked him.
It was a mass of flesh, distorted and disfigured,
like a bloated, coagulated wound given form.
It might once have been a person, but now
extra legs had sprouted beneath it, arms having
melted into slimy, blood-red tendrils that
were flailing in pain as the creature tried
to douse the fire.
Boba backed out of the shack’s front entrance,
still firing his carbine blaster.
Its bolts were having little effect on the
fleshy, inhuman monster, seeming to only cause
it irritation rather than leaving any lasting
damage.
But as the infamous hunter moved his foot
behind him, a wooden porch step snapped beneath,
causing him to topple over, landing on his
back in the snow.
His blaster had fallen from his hands as he
came crashing down, forcing him to roll over
and reach for it.
That’s when he saw the others…
Emerging from the abandoned, rural town, a
group of nightmarish abominations were slithering
out of nearby shacks.
They shambled towards Boba, each one of them
looking different from the next, but no less
stomach-churning in their fleshy, blood-soaked
appearances.
Some were bipedal, walking on the remnants
of two legs, but with their entire upper body
fused into a single, monstrous mass.
Others looked like they had once been small
animals, but had been cruelly and unnaturally
twisted into amorphous, slimy mutations of
their former selves.
The horde of beings, a veritable smorgasbord
of Flesh That Hates, were crawling towards
Boba.
He had spent the earliest parts of his childhood
surrounded by cloners on Kamino, alien experts
in genetics.
Since then, he’d been all over the galaxy,
and met people of all different species.
It wasn’t hard for Boba to see what these
things, these monsters, were.
They were the townsfolk that lived in this
snow-covered place.
Or, at least, they used to be people.
Now they were horrific.
From behind him, the first creature – the
one that had drawn him out – re-emerged,
still enraged.
But, as he turned to look at it, making sure
he was aware of all threats surrounding him,
Boba spotted its skin.
The parts where he had singed it with his
flamethrower were still severely burned, practically
reduced to a cinder.
Fire.
That could hurt them.
Reaching to the ground to retrieve and stow
his blaster, Boba felt something tugging at
the weapon, pulling it in the opposite direction.
Another of the fleshy monsters, a crawling,
spider-like collection of arms and legs with
no body or head, had flung an appendage outwards
and grabbed the carbine.
Trying to pull it back, Boba slipped in the
snow, and was being dragged towards the writhing
monstrosity.
A loud bang echoed around the nearby town,
punctuated by a bright, red light soaring
through the sky and gently floating back down
towards the ground.
The white-hot flare filled the area with a
glow, the creatures all momentarily turning
their attention to it, sensing its heat.
That split second was his one chance, all
of Boba’s instincts, every lesson Jango
had taught him, told him to strike first if
he wanted to make it away alive.
He dropped the blaster, leaving it in the
creature’s grip – he had spares back on
the Firespray, but they’d be no good to
him if he was dead.
Hitting one of the tiny switches on his vambrace,
two scorching hot flames spat from the exhausts
of Boba’s jetpack.
Immediately, he was lifted up off the ground,
hovering just above the roofs of the small
wooden structures around him.
In that same microsecond, the abominations
of flesh turned their collective attention
back to their airborne prey.
The ones that still had heads, or had grown
extra, disfigured, and misshapen growths in
place of a head, looked up at Boba; to them,
he was merely another vessel for them to infect
with the same disease that plagued them.
But little did any of them know, he was the
Boba Fett, the galaxy’s deadliest, most
infamous, Beskar-clad bounty hunter – and
a good bounty hunter was never unarmed.
Igniting in an instant, the flickering nozzle
end of Boba’s wrist-mounted flamethrower
began spraying super-heated fuel over the
horde of monstrosities below.
Long tongues of orange flame engulfed the
writhing, slithering creatures, burning them
to a crisp as Boba Fett rained unrelenting
hell down on the Flesh That Hates.
Hovering above them, he had given himself
enough high ground to gain an advantage.
Ironically, the distance Boba had to put between
himself and the monsters wasn’t dissimilar
to the detachment he had for those he had
killed or captured for Jabba the Hutt in the
past.
They had all been people too, just like these
twisted masses of flesh had once been human.
Pushing those thoughts down, like he’d been
taught to, Boba’s attention was focused
on blasting any of the fleeing creatures,
burning them with enough intensity to leave
little behind but charred remains.
Except he had forgotten, in his haste, to
check behind him.
The monster that had first attacked him was
making quick work of scaling the nearest single-story
shack, and flailed one of its appendages at
Boba.
It caught him in mid-air, plucking him out
of the sky and wrenching him back down to
the snowy ground once more.
Winded, Boba was gasping to catch his breath
underneath his helmet.
He certainly didn’t need to look to know
his jetpack had most likely been damaged by
his fall.
But that was currently the least of his worries.
Towering above, looming over him, the repulsive
monster looked like it was rearing up to pounce.
Boba reached to relight his flamethrower,
only for his gauntlet to spark; it had taken
a hit on the way down too.
Desperation set it, he lifted his knee and
fired two darts from the micro cannons mounted
on his yellow kneepads.
The spiked darts became embedded in the fleshy
creature’s mass, barely fazing it.
Loading a wrist rocket, Boba raised his other
vambrace to fire, only for the arm he wore
it on to be grabbed by one of the other creatures,
still-burning, half-alive.
Meanwhile, the one on the roof looked ready
to leap.
It sprung into the air, ready to come crashing
down to kill the feared former bounty hunter.
A bright light burst from somewhere nearby;
it wasn’t another flare, this one was a
blinding eruption of pure white.
Even through the tinted T-shaped visor of
his helmet, it stung Boba’s eyes so much
that he had to cover his face with his hand.
As he peered back, he almost mistook the light
grey of the sky for the same light.
Looking around, the monster had vanished.
Those that were left were still writhing,
their amorphous bodies coated with fire, which
was rapidly spreading to the wood of the nearby
houses.
Keeping his guard up, as he always did, Boba
climbed to his feet, lifting the gauntlet
with a miniature blaster mounted on it to
defend himself.
He’d seen, and even used, disintegration
weapons in the past, but the bounty hunter
had never known anything to make a creature
like that monster completely vanish in a single
flash.
He turned at a sound, not one of the creatures
or the gentle crackling of flames, but the
gentle crunch of snow under someone’s foot.
Three strangers walked slowly up to Boba,
not one among them flinching when he lifted
his vambrace, standing his ground.
Their clothing was patchwork, cobbled together
from scraps, but looked similar to the same
cloaks worn by the Jedi of old.
As the group approached him, the bounty hunter
noticed their bodies had also been altered,
although not in the same way as the vile,
fleshy creatures that now littered the snow
around him.
Metalwork, mechanized components, and devices
of all manner protruded from their uncovered
arms and necks, pieces of machinery embedded
in their skulls in the place of their eyes.
Boba was no stranger to cyborgs, those who
had modified their own bodies with technological
augmentations and modifications.
One of the three was missing an entire hand,
in its place was what looked to be some kind
of cannon, still warm from having just fired.
The cloaked, mechanized trio looked at Fett
with curiosity, as if they were examining…
no, admiring his armor.
Just like his damaged ship, Boba’s armor
belonged to his father, and if these three
wanted to take it, they’d have to kill him
for it.
“I take it that was your flare that distracted
them?” he growled beneath his helmet.
The frontmost of the group nodded, bowing
his head gently, indicating he meant no harm.
“Indeed.
We saw something, a vessel, we believe, fall
from the sky not far from here,” the part-man,
part-machine replied.
“Was that your craft, warrior?”
Lowering his arm at last, Boba nodded in response.
“Don’t suppose you know where I can get
my ship fixed?”
the hunter asked.
“We may be able to assist you,” one of
the other two interjected.
“You have machinery, we watched you use
it to fight.
Are you one of us?”
“I give my allegiance to no one,” Boba
stated as he eyed the speaker; he barely looked
older than a teenager.
“Who are you people?”
“Some have called us Mekhanites, others
know us as the Church of the Broken God,”
the leader spoke up in reply.
“Little of that matters now, not since the
Flesh overran this place.
They spread via skin contact, only the parts
of our bodies we have yet to mechanize are
still vulnerable to their infection.
I certainly hope none of them touched you,
warrior.”
Boba took a look over his shoulder at the
bodies of the still-burning creatures, glad
that his helmet was pressurized and his flight
suit was on tight.
“The Flesh,” he muttered to himself.
“I’m fine,” he declared with certainty.
“In that case,” the lead Mekhanite said.
“Let’s see about fixing your ship, shall
we?”
Now go and check out “SCP-096 vs SCP-343”
and “SCP-049 vs SCP-173” if you want to
hear about the outcomes of more chaotic clashes
between anomalies battling each other for
supremacy!